As you know, the performance appraisal process...
...is a very important process here at Keystone College...
...because it provides us with an opportunity to talk about what's going on in your work,...
...gives you a chance to tell me if you have any concerns or issues,...
...and it also provides me with an opportunity to share with you...
...how you are supporting the whole strategic planning process,...
...the strategic goals of our department and of the college.
So, with that, let's look at first your goals from last year.
You did an excellent job on the department report.
Thanks, I worked really hard on that.
I could tell.
The column headings clearly describe the material...
...and the calculations in the report were all correct and in an easy-to-read format.
Excellent job.
And you submitted it early, so that was a bonus, too.
So, that was awesome.
So, moving on, let's look at the different categories here.
And that you also rated in your self-evaluation form as well.
For customer service here, I rated you as "meets expectations."
In regard to teamwork, I have that you have done an above-average job.
You had worked on a project where you filled in as the team leader.
You took the team leader role...
...and you actually had the department work on this major transaction goal...
...and you accomplished that.
And it took leadership skills and communication skills for you...
...to get everybody else to cooperate and work with you and accomplish that...
...and you did an excellent job with that.
Thank you, I appreciate that.